and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the Karate Kid
my job is the greatest movie I've ever
seen in my life
wax on wax boilers is this kid from
America and he moves to China who
Muppets ready and he falls in love with
this trainee and girl but unfortunately
she's be true dish so I'm a trainee
invoice she's patron who gets really mad
and he's like wah you think you can
steal my girlfriend I'm going to punch
you now Oh so the American boy is like I
need to learn karate so I can kick some
ass but the only person I know around
here is Jackie Chan with Jackie Chan is
Jackie Chan so the boy is like can you
teach me crazy
no how about you fool okay ba so Jackie
Chan start teaching kung fu so it really
should be called the kungfu kid but
unfortunately there's no website where
it's all instead we got coat on coat off
I told everybody I know Samantha wax on
wax off method in fact I know a guy who
tells me you wax off all the time but
everything is I developed a new method
from it to drink and drink our way of
karate begun jingle jingle jingle I'm
telling you it really works I just
choose net fight so Jessie she tells him
that the reason is doing the proton
proton research on that girl foo is
everywhere which I kiss makes a little
bit more sense than you we do know is
this one it's like what did you use that
weight to show me to fight to show you
that kung foo is everywhere original
it's like why did you use it way to show
me to fight so because the point those
had to take his jacket on and off he now
knows kung foo I heard kung foo that way
once or was it pulled it either way I
ended up naked don't register submits
the boy into a tournament so he can
fight the evil trying to mean boy
like Jackie Chan is like like Yoda
I am NOT I know it you are but lots of
money you will be so Jackie Chan ties
into the Great Wall of China to learn
more comfy right a and of course see
this woman dancing with a Cobra
and Jackie Chan is like is the Cobra
controlling her or is she controlling
the Cobra which is it don't know Wow
don't change it takes into the
tournament and he practices his coach
foo the other fighters are like do the
cool thing is weird I quit hurry
but then the big bad teacher comes over
to the little bad children and he's like
break the little boy's leg teacher wing
is much honored so immersing me little
boy hurts his leg and he gets
disqualified and then a second boy break
his leg and he always wins the bet but
does that make they never end up in the
original ether if you Brendan that's
okay you injury you need a timeout weird
so he goes Kerri Strug other ass and
defense it's the whole thing with one
leg how I using the Cobra I'm
controlling you now watch my matrix move
everything she wins with weird and
possible backflip ethen buddy and the
big bad teacher is like where did I
teach you kids no pay no mercy and the
kids are like yeah sorry for any kid is
a really great movie made even better
than the original but I really could
have used a Hilary Swank performance
maybe that can be the sequel the kid
grows up changes the conference can
become a woman just like Michael Jackson
too soon this is history bouncing change
you got sighs I come on epic I am real
J come on I use it to fund this week
water and we have a few quarters so the
teacher will probably be seats